on the 16th of December 1944 a massive
art
Ariba Raj caught Allied forces off-guard
signaling the start of an unexpected
German counter-offensive in the quiet
Ardenne forests their intention split
the Allied lines in half and ultimately
claimed the valuable harbour at Antwerp
their timing is impeccable with the cold
winds of winter blowing in our superior
air forces have been grounded and the
Germans are taking full advantage of the
situation to full Panzer divisions hit
the weakly defended low sign gap along a
45 mile front driving deep into Belgium
and Luxembourg within 24 hours of the
Germans unleashing their desperate
offensive the initiative in the battle
for Europe completely changed hands the
fifth Panzer Division attacks Bastogne
and safe feet aiming to capture these
strategic road junctions and secure
their hold on the region US forces now
scramble to stem the tide of Germans
pouring into allied territory though our
lines may have been our men will not
break the German offensive will be
turned back
you